this morning we are focusing on
something millions of americans are
dealing with every single day but very
few talk about it more than six million
women in this country have trouble
getting or staying pregnant that's
according to the cdc now that's about 10
percent of those who were of
childbearing age tv personality and
founder of the lv guide that's liliana
vasquez when she realized it was going
to be difficult for her to get pregnant
she kept it to herself for national
infertility awareness week we asked
liliana to share her own path to
motherhood with cbs mornings
in the fall of 2015 i was asked to sit
on the panel of a new network show
for a girl from fort worth texas who
spoke english as her second language let
me tell you it was a dream come true one
morning right before we went live my
cell phone rang
my stomach dropped as soon as i saw the
number on my screen
it was my ob gyn calling with blood work
results women are born with around 2
million eggs which is all the eggs
they'll ever have
at the onset of menopause most women
only have around a thousand left
my doctor called to share that at just
35 years young my hormone levels
indicated that i could be dangerously
close to that number
she followed up with the one question
that changed the course of the next six
years
do you want to be a mother
i still get emotional saying that
question out loud
because up until that moment i hadn't
really thought about it i was the career
girl
i was the woman who prioritized my job
above almost all else
now here i was broken on a bathroom
floor
crying over something i never realized i
wanted so badly
when i finally composed myself
i answered her question with a
resounding yes
but my journey to motherhood would not
come easily
infertility had taken agency over my
body i was ashamed
embarrassed and i didn't want anyone to
know
so i made a decision to keep my
diagnosis as private as possible
over the next few years i saw every
specialist i could find hundreds of
needles filled containers in my kitchen
cabinets i cannot wait until all of this
is finally over each one was a testament
to the battle i was fighting tiny swords
i wielded each day in my war on
infertility
months turned to years and before i knew
it
we had lost seven embryos
back at it again
i started to lose track of all of the
appointments the ultrasounds the blood
draws
i started to lose track of myself
when you're battling infertility a bad
day feels unbearable
a good day still feels hopeless
each failed cycle made me question
myself was i woman enough good enough or
even committed enough to get pregnant
could we be happy if life for just the
two of us
was i enough
for me
faith came in the form of one word
i remember walking off offset defeated
after yet another negative pregnancy
test when a co-worker came over and
whispered surrender
her simple instruction started a seismic
shift in the acceptance of my journey i
learned how to release the idea of
pregnancy and instead opened my heart to
parenthood
i stopped obsessing over the statistics
that would never be in my favor
my worth wouldn't be tied to a follicle
count or an fsh level anymore because no
matter what the number said
i had always been worthy
of becoming a mother on election day
2020
we transferred one of our last embryos
as they wheeled me into the room i did
my best to let go
i closed my eyes and surrendered to our
greatest wish of all
just to be parents
santi lived only in our hearts for six
years
but then
on july 19 2021 our brave beautiful boy
came into this world and healed my
heart every night i feel his tiny body
relax and somehow grow so heavy in my
arms i can see the outline of his
beautiful lashes that perfect nose
and his little lips pursed together
somehow telling me without words mama
thank you
i'm safe
and happy
and so loved
ivf showed me how to grieve and grow and
that faith arrives when you face your
biggest fears
i learned there's freedom and
forgiveness and above all
boundless strength and vulnerability
liliana is here lily i say mama thank
you too did you ever think you could
feel such love you would kill for this
little creature i know it i absolutely
would i think i said it too best i love
my husband with all my heart i'd
probably kill him for this baby too i
mean i don't know that i've ever felt
this and i didn't know that that was a
feeling that was missing for me for so
long what struck me about your piece
number one it's beautifully done and
very very powerful when you said you go
you were ashamed and embarrassed and you
didn't want to say thank you for getting
over that and sharing your story with
all of us but what were you ashamed and
embarrassed about this was something
that wasn't beyond your control we have
to dig into why people women feel this
way you know for me i felt broken and i
felt like the one thing i should be able
to do is get pregnant and have a baby
it's all i had thought was easy right
and then all of a sudden i couldn't do
it no matter how tri how hard i tried i
couldn't control that and i feel like so
many women who are battling ivf feel so
much shame in that why can't my body
just do this one thing um and i didn't
want to share that because i didn't want
to be pitied either you know i think
that's really important for me i wanted
to
be strong and confident and i didn't
want people to look at me and be like oh
she can't get pregnant yeah
but you weren't even sure you wanted a
baby in the beginning it's only when the
doctor asked that question absolutely
true absolutely you know i was never
that person who picked out names in
advance and it wasn't until that very
moment i think and it happens a lot in
life when people
take something away from you or the
opportunity to have something is taken
away from you it becomes crystal clear
all i could see was myself as a mother
at that point yeah it's a very
clarifying moment you're only 35 years
old at the time you thought you had
years to go i had no i thought i could
have a baby whenever i wanted it it was
on my schedule according to my plan it
wasn't you're a career woman you think
yes and that was the most important
thing for you that was what my focus was
on right it was on my relationship my
friends it was on travel it was
adventure and my focus wasn't on being a
mom or being a parent that could come in
time but it wasn't what i really wanted
in that moment until my doctor asked
that question and that is really what
changed the course of the next six years
of my life for me and i had never been
more grounded and more clear in the fact
that i wanted to be a mother and i
wanted to be a parent i was telling you
while the piece was running that i love
that you used the technical terms for
the follicle counts and all this because
the people who are going through this
you know the average person may not know
what it is but the millions of people
going through this they know what that
is oh you know you hear fsh and you go
oh god not again not again what is it
how low is it or follicle counts right
those numbers dominated my life for so
long until i was finally able to let
that go so now that you're on the other
side of it what what is your message to
those people those millions of people
who are in it right now you know i think
the biggest shift for me was shifting
from fear to acceptance right and and
what does that mean that means that when
you're going into these appointments you
know fear says oh i only have six
follicles or fear says we only have two
embryos but what acceptance is is it
only takes one it only takes one egg and
it only took one for me to have santiago
and that shift is what gives people hope
and i really hope that people see this
and know that there's still hope i think
it's so important that you tell your
story because i remember you know very
ignorantly on my part years ago a couple
had been married a couple years and i
said are you guys planning to have
children they said well yeah and i said
well what are you waiting for it's easy
i mean that's so stupid when you don't
know and she goes actually gail it's not
and the way she looked at me i felt such
shame that i because i'm trying to be
hahaha funny i felt such shame that i
had done that to her that's why it's so
important that you educate us about
what we may or may not know because when
you said when battling a bad day feels
unbearable a good day feels still feels
hopeless absolutely because there's bad
news at every turn and there's so much
loss in ivf it's not just you know
getting pregnant and having a
miscarriage when you're going through
ivf you're losing embryos you're
canceling transfers you know there is so
much trauma in that and everything
becomes a trigger and so when somebody
says something like that even though you
know you're joking and trying to be
light about it but it's not funny it's
not funny and it's so deeply painful and
i think the more we talk about it the
more we normalize ivf and infertility
people will stop in second guess asking
that question because you never know
what somebody is fighting for privately
and the best thing about santi is what
his laugh you heard it right you heard
it right there that baby but by the way
you got to work for those laughs he's
not that baby that's serving them up at
every corner so every day i'm out there
like doing the craziest dances and
making the faces but that laugh lights
up my heart and it'll light up our lives
for for forever perfect little nose as
well oh happy for you liliana thank you
so much happy ending to the story thank
you for having me here to share more on
we needed you today oh thank you juliana
vasquez we appreciate it